wisst ihr was wir machen es einfach
hardcore jetzt auch im deathmatch gilt
ich darf er nur angreifen welche fragen
richtig beantworten
die darf ich auch noch eine frage an den
ok ist hätten gegner frage fallen
schnell services und herzlich willkommen
zurück zur zweiten folge community
change heute wieder einen quiz aber wir
spielen jump league und das sieht wie
folgt aus wie immer bin ich hier mit ein
paar zuschauern im channel und die
stämme fragen
heute darf ich aber nur dann wieder
kisten auf machen wenn die frage richtig
beantwortet wurde
das ist die die auflage für jump liegt
also die bezüglichen jump league nur auf
kisten und im deathmatch würde ich erst
mal sagen nicht auf gegner weil das so
turbulent ist aber wir werden das sehen
ich schaue das okay ich bin bei der
ersten kiste hier frage ich davon
ok aus holz okay aber diese antwort
falsch antwortet falsche antwort
du brauchst acht blöcke mal 972 okay
beim papa ich liebe es ist nicht scheiße
scheiße
van gaal ich habe es für wechsel dich
spiel einfach abschlachten selbst keine
ahnung herrscht ein mittel auf
nun ist guter rat der name nicht
eingefallen ich hatte das bild schon vor
augen sagt du musst auf ok muss gut mit
rekord also wir machen das hier ganz
ganz ganz heißer professional ich ziehe
jetzt 85
wir sind trotzdem auf platz eins sehr
geil nächste frage ich bin eine kiste
weil es am ende kein orden gibt keine
ahnung keine sonne
ok keine calais gaal nicht vor dem 31
expert alter ja wann das neue name also
ich will mit dem namen fire ist richtig
wer bist du ach ja du bist auch tsmc spd
wie viele truhen tode zwölf u3 ich bin
dumm das hätte ich gewusst ich war beim
1 nächste frage
das seltenste wird es erst gestorben
erst erste des war von logo an lilo also
nicht ausgestorben als erste
gg wir können heute machen von äpfeln
warte ich bin doch gar nicht eine kiste
aber egal wie viele arten von es gibt
einen normalen gott es gibt erwartet
apfel gold apfel-logo apfel erdapfel 33
äpfel glaube ich also drei sehr schöne
kann ich jetzt kann jetzt ihr die fragen
davon ist immer mitnehmen so egal steht
noch eine stimme noch eines der
seltensten spawn rate von bismarck akten
zwei blöcke prozent können weil ich guck
mal nach ich guck mal nach wenn es
richtig jetzt bin ich hier gerade
irgendwo diesen abschnitt sich gerade
zum ersten mal mcs belaufen
ich schwöre ist soll die schwer weil das
geht garnicht alter sack
mcs paradise dankeschön und mein leben
also ich hab ich ja fast noch nichts
wissen von leichen im schwarzen tür
zugeschlagen mit einer dieser parcours
ist neu ist der gefällt mir gut
da ist das mein leben völlig okay jetzt
hier sind bei dem kuchen parcours jetzt
auch noch mal tricky nice first rays
wichtig es ist man die viel spott ich
habe die kiste zu schnell auf gemacht
ich brauche wieder infrage
eine rynair dem 1 1 3533 ist hast du
brauchst 25 auer 2 dann brauchst du ja
vier richtig was soll ich habe gar nicht
nach ganz einfach nur mathematisch
logischen extra lang nein nein ich war
darunter
mein auto mein leben alter ich bin nur
noch nie runter gefallen naja jetzt
geht's los
angela merkel ich grüße an bord gut an
dieser stelle möchte auch größe durchaus
anguilla anguilla
ich kriege es auch den amerikanern
risikofaktor runde zu ende
ok dann wisst ihr was wir machen es
einfach hardcore jetzt auch im
deathmatch gilt ich darf er nur
angreifen wenn ich fragen richtig
beantworten
die darf ich auch noch nachfragen okay
es hingeht nachfrage folge schnell
niedrigste stufe reisen dafür nicht
nötig da will ich muss sterben
ok nein ich wollte ich habe stark
ansteigen gedachte für diese frage
schnellschüsse die graf mich an hier
schnell
ach du scheiße hatte 3 ok ok nächste 12
sekunden also meedia.de debatte 10 7 10
sekunden junge ich sterbe die ganz
schnell sterben acht gold gold gold
angreifen
ich habe gesündigt und stellen fragen
fragen fragen
nicht so plump frage was es zu krass
gott oh gott oh gott ihm so schnell
nächste frage 72 72
darf ich einfach noch ein kind sehr
schön 30 sekunden alter aber schöne
runde jungs wieder schönere und wird
sagen wir starten auf jeden fall noch
mal versucht ob wir auch mal so eine
quick change runde gewinnen können
erstmal danke fürs dabeisein wieder an
euch danke für eure aufmerksamkeit
colombo und an euch zuschauer draußen
wieder auf